AND THREE TOP THEY'VE GOT JOHN N
IN GOAL AND NOWRST FIVE OF 12thT
YEAR, TAKING A SHOT THERE,
NEDELIJKOVIC STOPPLE, THE UNDERD
DEFENSEMAN BEHIND SEIDER
AND A PASS, PICKED UP THERE,
SMARTLYY
COMING BACK BY, WHO ELSE? HAPPE.
KEN: SUTER, BERTUZZI, IN DEEP,
CIRCLING THE WAGON MADE
THAT TOP LINE, STILL SOHN GIBSOE
ALL-STAR GAME AND WILL GET
VEZINANAAYS, AS THEY
SAY, WHEN YOU HIT FEBRUARY AND S
TIME AHEAD FOR FILIP ZADINA.H, !
!
KEN: AND ARMSTRONG AND
WESTERN MI
SHOT, SAVE MADE, NEDELIJKOVIC.
ABOVE THE GOAL ICING LINE.
MICKEY: PERIOD
SINCE JOININ
ATHREE-ON-TWO.
DETROIT BEINGNG
DETROIT, 3.5 WEEKS IS IN FRONT W
LINDSTROM M
OH, HE COULD HAVE WALKED IN,
EVEN THE NHL, FOWLER
WITH F UP TO
POORLY ABOUT THOSE FROM TORONTO.
KEN: I'M. HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF
WHERE THEY STAND WHEN THEY HIS S
TOTALS FOR A PENALTY
CALL AND THEY DO NOT GET ONE AND
WHAT A MOVE RIGHT
OESTERLE, A SHOT, HE SCORES!